hey you guys what's going on it's the
movie retrospective and we're talking
about uh I guess it's like a classic
Western but it's also kind of like
a different modern kind of Western it
was at the time Unforgiven yeah from
1992 Best Picture Winner that year
matter of fact one of only three I think
it was only three westerns that ever won
best picture I remember seeing I don't
think I saw this in the theater like
when it came out but I'm not usually
like a big westerns person like I've
seen a lot that I liked but I remember
seeing this one I think I rented it like
maybe a year or two after it came out
and I remember really really liking it
but I don't think that I had seen it
since then so I was like really excited
to re-watch it and yeah this is a great
[ __ ] movie this is a great [ __ ]
movie I remember when it was out
everybody was talking about it yeah yeah
yeah it was a big deal it was a good
movie and what's what's great about it
is that you can tell it's a it's like
kind of like an indie flick in in terms
of budget it's not super high budget 14
million I think that's nothing but a day
and it made like way more than that back
obviously but because the writing was so
good in it yeah yeah
um it was a no [ __ ] Western they
tried to
kind of expose the myths of the [ __ ]
that was like the best thing about it I
think that's like one of the main themes
I feel like
um is that it's kind of skewering the
mythology behind the American West you
know what I mean which I could I think
it's kind of going back they call it a
revisionist western which is usually
that's a whole sub-genre on unto itself
and that uh if it's a revisionist
western that usually means it's like
more morally gray or more morally
ambiguous because in contrast to maybe
like the pre-spaghetti Western era where
westerns were very like black and white
like the morality so it's kind of trying
to show you know the American West more
like it actually was rather than like
Heroes villains blackout white hat you
know yeah no it was it was a picture of
everything right it was kind of like
some you'd see in the modern world
basically just criminals a lot of them a
lot of them are just criminals and then
you had guys who were good or trying to
stop the criminality and uphold law but
they were bad too kind of yeah they were
they were had a lot of human Frailty in
them and uh corruption it was just
human behavior you know but uh this is
this is a good good movie and it goes in
Clint Eastwood's kind of going out of
his way to go hey look gunfighters were
[ __ ] criminals okay they shot people
in the mouth for no good reason because
they were drunk they did things you know
then they they didn't remember what they
did they would just run away sometimes
you know in a hail of bullets and then
just didn't realize how lucky they were
to get away you know
um
because during the time of the what we
would call the old west
they had pulp writers going in there
right and basically superhero novels on
what was going on in the way and selling
them yeah and there's a reference yeah
they got a character in here like that
right and they kind of exposed the
[ __ ] of those pulp novels back in
the 1800s what they were saying about
you know what they were writing that's
not the way it was
that was uh they were making comic books
really based on what was happening
but that's not what those guys were like
you know dude some of them were bombs
basically
yeah and like I said I think that's the
best thing about this movie is that it
really does kind of like expose this
whole like gunfighter as hero or like
the whole romantic the whole
romanticizing of that and it's he's kind
of trying to show the way it really was
it's like there was nothing Noble
about them it's like most of the time
they were just mad yeah they were just
mad or drunk or they just like killed
people they weren't really thinking
about it and he's kind of like Clint
Eastwood's character in particular uh
his name is William money he was kind of
like one of those guys that you know
would have been mythologized in like an
older Western like he just went around
and towned like shot people and you know
he was like a crack shot and all this
other kind of [ __ ] like he was an outlaw
but he's kind of gotten to a place in
his life now where he just regretted
like everything that he ever did and he
was just like I was a piece of [ __ ]
human being and I killed women and
children without even thinking about it
I was just drunk all the time and you
know so there's nothing like romantic
about that at all and now he's kind of
trying to make amends by raising his
kids you know even the members of the of
the gang that he was in the group were
scared of him and or didn't like him
right yeah I mean so it wasn't even
there wasn't even any camaraderie among
these Outlaws you know they couldn't
stand each other
so they point that out you know and just
it's a good flick because he's all this
character Monty uh William Money I think
yeah he's already a legend all right
yeah people know about him but he's been
hiding
and what they believe about him is
partially true but not really he wasn't
you know they were like there's a scene
where the pulpruder is going like okay
you just killed Five Guys in here
this is it and he's he's referring his
to his own books and what other gun
Fighters told him he says you're
supposed to shoot the fastest or the
biggest threat first so which one did
you share it first and he goes I don't
know because you don't know he goes no I
was just lucky in the order yeah yeah
because but I've always been lucky at
killing people yeah
and uh there wasn't any
first thing he does well um
they capture his friend and torture him
and he dies during the torture and they
put him in a box out in front of
Greeley's store it was a store it was a
saloon it was a saloon I think this is a
saloon yeah I think it was called
skinnies yeah or great no I guess it was
called Greeley's right the guy's name
was skinny yeah and they're in there
forming a posse to go out for run after
William money and he walks in they were
gonna he thought they thought he was on
the Run no he went to him just walked
right in they turned around he's
standing right there with a shotgun or
it might have been a lever action rifle
but I think no I think you start off
with a shotgun double barrel shotgun
and he goes all right who owns this
[ __ ] and he goes I am the owner of
this establishment he just blows him
away boom and the sheriff because you
just killed an unarmed man and he goes
well he should have armed himself if he
was going to decorate this [ __ ] with
my friend out front which that's a lot
closer to the way the old west was they
shot people in the back they did all
kinds of stuff you know what I mean it
was they were murderers yeah basically
like I said there was no nobility in it
really they weren't like heroic or
anything and there was there wasn't too
many of those you know I'll meet you out
back high noon and we're gonna duke it
out in the street you know fair and
square like a duel nah now it's
bushwhacking assassinations murder
getting drunk in the middle of a card
game and opening fire in a [ __ ]
crowded place they did that but there
were some misconceptions about the old
west in general guns weren't allowed in
town you had to check them in at the
sheriff's office which they show in here
too big whiskey is the name of it yeah
um it was mostly peaceful mostly
peaceful in the old west per you know
per capita the crime wasn't
out of control really when you think
about it um nothing compared to what
you'd find today is just that when
something went down everybody heard
about it there were Outlaws there were
criminals they made a bigger impression
back then because the population was a
lot lower that's what I'm saying I think
it was more a case of that like you just
weren't as many people so it was easier
to like make a mythology about somebody
that maybe yeah didn't you know didn't
do and I think one of the best scenes in
this too that's kind of like emblematic
of you know myth making is you know the
kind of inciting incident of the whole
plot which is you know the The
Prostitute the girl getting her face cut
up yeah and you know it's bad her face
is all cut up and it's scarred and
everything like that but you can see
like as it goes on like the before they
actually see her in person the story of
what her injuries are is like way
embellished like way way worse than it
actually was like a game a telephone but
right the Assassins or the the the guns
for hire heard about it you know they
thought her tongue had been cut out her
eyes have been cutting they cut off her
finger there's a pulled her fingers and
toes up and cut her breasts off and [ __ ]
you know but that's not what happens is
she just got slashed up a little bit on
the face yeah
um which like I said that's bad but it
was it wasn't anything like for laughing
at a dude's dick yeah that is microbe he
was he was drunk and he [ __ ] lashed
out at her yeah they tried to buy her
off
and what was said is that
the dude's friend who had nothing to do
with it got caught up in the middle of
it he tried to fix it but he got killed
yeah if I remember correctly so innocent
dudes were going down with the guilty
which is that's the way [ __ ] went then
too yeah and and the thing about this
one like I said every single character
is morally ambiguous just like in real
life like some of the characters do
really bad [ __ ] but then some of the
characters like the same characters like
aren't all bad like they all have both
you know attributes well even the even
the head hooker she's trying to get
Justice for her friend who got caught up
but even she's maximizing it she's
blowing it way out of proportion
um try and hire an assassins and uh
turning down uh monies for for
um uh what was it restitution they were
trying to give her and I was an innocent
guy who tried to give her a horse yeah
because he felt bad about what his
friend said yeah so it was just um
and and the actual victim of the crime
is like kind of like an innocent
bystander she didn't doesn't even really
want to get involved they're you know
her
uh she I guess she's not a pimp but it's
her boss the head yeah the Madam she's
the one that's that that's really well
and all the other I mean and the thing
about it is like the thing about it is
that like you can understand like I said
because this is the inciting incident
you can understand their outrage this
poor girl's face was all cut up and now
they're saying well she's a prostitute
so now she's not going to be able to do
her job anymore or at least not be able
to command the same seller or whatever
the [ __ ] you know what I mean yeah um
because nobody will ask for it because
her face is all messed up now yeah
um and I think what so that was like you
know really bad but then the problem was
like compounded by the sheriff he's
played by Gene Hackman Little Bill his
name is and he was gonna whip them which
probably would have been okay yeah just
women um but the other guy was innocent
what would they whip that guy for well
yeah but they you know they were
together so he just figured like no by
association yeah but then
um you know the The Madam was was like
well that's all you're gonna do like she
you know he he took away like her
ability to like do her job essentially
because he cut her face all up and so
then after that like but then Gene
Hackman is like oh well now we're not
even gonna whip him now we're just gonna
like pay now you just have to pay the
guy that like bought the prostitute's
contract yeah so he gets the money so he
gets the money not her so she doesn't
get anything so like the prostitutes
were like [ __ ] this [ __ ] yeah and they
all pooled all their money and they said
and they put out a call they're like we
want assassins to come and kill these
two dudes which like I said is you know
what he did was bad but it probably
didn't warrant that like if they'd been
whipped and stuff like that that
probably would have been okay and then
maybe some monetary compensation would
have been in order also the innocent guy
tried to do that right he's the one that
got caught up in it he gave her what a
choice like a pony which
it wasn't really a pony it was a young
horse but uh but maybe they would call
it a pony back then a smaller horse uh
but some people like a pony that's it
that was worth a lot of money back then
yeah she could have sold that would have
been like a high-end car back in the
1800s yeah um
she could have sold it and got the
[ __ ] what's his name
her pimp [ __ ] is the one that got all
the damn money he got I think he got
seven or five yeah I think it ended up
being like six or seven horses something
like that because they said yeah and he
didn't have to like pay the horses right
then they said oh next spring like after
the thoughts I think it was winter time
and it's like next spring bring us you
bring me five ponies and you bring me
two or whatever and give them to skinny
right who is like the boss so like the
girl that got cut up didn't get Jack
yeah it was to uh and it had to do with
the the fact that it it was kind of like
damages against this contract that he
had so because she was property like he
he bought her contract right and so
that's like uh the indentured servitude
was [ __ ] real common it was yeah
people forget all about it yeah but no
[ __ ] white people were slaves they
just did it a different way and you had
to buy and sell contracts especially
women and Irish or kind of some of them
were under contracts yeah with the
railroad and the Chinese and they just
mowed them down like nothing yeah they
didn't give us give a [ __ ] the Irishman
was worth nothing I mean they were let
less than not less than nothing they
were like a liability you know
but that didn't last long they they
stopped all that [ __ ] and it wasn't the
government it was these corporations man
the corporations had more power power
than the government the government had
no power in Washington DC they couldn't
reach out and do anything everything was
local well and I kind of feel like
especially too like out west too because
it was just so it was outside the U.S
territory I mean that's far right
um so yeah the the the the the the the
prostitute [ __ ] I forgot what her
name was when they got caught up now
here's the thing they were saying that
she's no good that she's useless she
wasn't that damaged by looking at it
unless they didn't have the special
effects money to make her look worse
well I think that was kind of the whole
point that it's like you know they
didn't know how it was gonna look like
when it healed yeah that would have
healed up and when it healed like it
looked kind of [ __ ] up but not I mean
you could still tell that she was a
pretty you know woman it would have been
so yeah they probably would have faded
away but I think that was kind of the
point and kind of the point too of you
know when Clint Eastwood uh you know
finds out about the contract against the
killers and it's a thousand dollars and
he's like oh you know my farm is failing
so maybe I should get in on some of that
money
um you know and they were talking about
her injuries like they were way way
worse but I think that's why because
they're like they're they're not saying
that her having her face cut up wasn't
bad it was but then like that being the
inciting incident which in the grand
scheme of like what ended up happening
like what ended up you know happening in
the wake of that was like so much like
many many times worse than that you know
what I mean and it's like and it wasn't
even
and it wasn't even like the fact that
she had her fingers cut off or her tits
cut off or anything like that like they
were saying yeah her face was cut up and
that sucked but you know the the
repercussions of it were like a million
times worse than like the initial
incident and I think that was the point
of her not really looking that bad in
the end yeah that would have healed up
she'd a bit she'd have been right it's
not like he ripped her open with a saw
or mutilated or anything it was a couple
of slices across the face with an
evidently a sharp knife which is better
than a Dull Knife okay because it it's a
cleaner cut and it heals up a lot better
it just looked like lines because then a
knife or was it but maybe it was a
straight razor I thought it was a
straight which that'd be even better
because that's just almost surgical it'd
heal right up if you put the bandages on
right taper up right or put a stitch or
two I don't even think she had stitches
so it couldn't have been very deep
um but uh she'd have been all right but
it brought down and the sheriff is like
you basically he's like you [ __ ] do
not know what you've done he goes that
one thousand dollar offer you put out
it's gonna Bounce About is gonna bring
in Monsters in here like you've never
[ __ ] and it did it did okay it did
because they they thought it was gonna
be easy but no that [ __ ] basically
destroyed the town it brought up
everybody I've heard about it like a
thousand dollars was a lot of money back
right and and the dudes that the dudes
that got involved in the little slicing
of the of the prostitute's face really
were just a bunch of cowboys they
weren't criminals or anything they were
working out at a ranch and they were
just working steps regular guys the one
dude really he should have been punished
for it the other guys just got caught up
in it they were
protected him from all these assassins
that were coming a lot of them get waxed
uh out out in what we call the Circle T
or the the team the bar team bar T yeah
we're at the bar T's where they worked
and that was one of the reasons why they
didn't want to whip them the sheriff the
sheriff was kind of trying to be
practical about it you know he's like
this is the source of the town's income
I can't really go down hard on these on
these Cowboys or I'll chase the business
away because that's where your tax
revenue is coming from so he really just
should have given that dude time that's
what I would have done yeah I mean at
least punish him obviously because what
he did was bad but it just seemed like
everybody's decisions yeah the thing
that's great about this movie like I
said and why the writing is so good it's
actually it was actually written by the
guy that co-wrote uh Blade Runner by the
way all right yeah uh David Webb peoples
and um so I think the great thing is
that everybody's decisions that they
made at the time
even if you wouldn't have done the same
thing like you can understand why that
person made that decision that doesn't
necessarily mean that they were a good
person but you know like it was gold
directed it was just right like
everybody had reasons for understandable
reasons for doing what they did Even
though like sometimes the repercussions
of that like were way [ __ ] up like
along the line you know really one of
the best characters in the movies the
sheriff all right yeah he's caught in
between a rock and a hard place he's
trying to bring civilization in in order
to a bunch of [ __ ] Savages basically
and they can't he's kind of
there's a lot of symbolism in his
character like he's trying to build a
house in his off time yeah which is kind
of symbolic of him trying to build a
nation or direct civilization it's not
working it's leaking he's a terrible
Carpenter
what's going on in this yeah he's
dealing with all these different people
and trying to keep peace between them in
some kind of civilized manner
uh civilization doesn't work in a
Frontier Town uh not really and this
this movie is a good demonstration of
why it doesn't work not real well
and um
you think he's kind of a heroic
character but you find out he's got a
bunch of failings too his head gets big
he gets real [ __ ] arrogant once once
he starts once he steals second English
Bob's uh biographer then he thinks he's
the star and starts [ __ ] cracking
down on people yeah like because yeah
because honestly like the first assassin
that shows up is not Clint Eastwood in
the and his uh little gang it's actually
a dude named English Bob and English Bob
shows up with this biographer like this
writer and he's written this book about
English Bob where he just like totally
polished his knob and laid made him seem
like the most awesome heroic gun fighter
of all time called him the Duke of death
is the name of the books and the [ __ ]
Sheriff's like nah the duck of days he
would not say duke he says duck every
time and he hates him he knows him from
before yeah and knows the truth about
him you know English Bob
uh which is the same dude who played a
[ __ ] what's his name of the man
called it's Richard Harris yeah he does
a great job he was in a [ __ ] Tony yes
he's very very famous and he's just uh
this arrogant British guy who shows up
insulting Americans and the president
on [ __ ] independence day and just you
know it's he called that a bunch of
himself you know England would Europe or
England wouldn't have you that kind of
[ __ ] this [ __ ] body but uh at all you
can see things a little bit from his
point of view sometimes it's just it's
just a good character good character he
is a really good gets his ass wit that
well that's the thing and the irony of
his character because like I said him
and Little Bill who's Gene Hackman's
character the sheriff they have like a
long history and like I said they kind
of hate each other but the thing about
it is that when English Bob shows up in
the town like you know looking to
collect on the Bounty that the
prostitutes have put forward
um and he's there with the with the
biographer and the biographer who is all
like all romanticizing all these
Gunslingers and everything and so like
little bill is reading this book and
being like this is a bunch of [ __ ]
and he's like I was there at this and
this isn't what happened like he's not a
heroic gun so like he shot people in the
back he just like shot people like I
don't know liver when he was drunk over
a woman right [ __ ] like that like there
was no nobility in it whatsoever but
then the irony of it is that after
English Bob gets his ass kicked and run
out of town on a rail and the biographer
decides to stay because now he thinks
that little bill is actually like way
cooler yeah and so then like little Bill
starts to get like a real inflated ego
too and he starts like you know walking
around like [ __ ] of the Walk yeah like
thinking that he's like the [ __ ] now
yeah and then later on at the end when
William comes in and wipes everyone out
just sucking in just a hot-blooded fury
the the biographer survives it gets up
and starts quizzing him and gets becomes
[ __ ] fascinated with this outlaw
and the outlaw doesn't live up to any of
his expectations based upon what these
other gun Fighters and
cops have told him you know about what
combat's like and uh he tries to hang
out with him but he was lucky to get
away with his life I don't I don't think
William William didn't kill him I think
he let him go I think he did and in the
end that biographer tried to help the
Posse kill William Money remember that
yeah he was there while they were
telling them to shoot
so they were all kind of [ __ ] bags yeah
everybody in this is kind of a [ __ ] bag
like uh too and even if they're not a
[ __ ] bag in the events like during the
events of the movie like Morgan
Freeman's character Ned yeah Ned was a
good guy he's a good guy now but but he
was a [ __ ] like back in the old days
just like uh William money was like
you're meant to apply like you don't see
you only see William money and Ned in
the nowadays when they've regretted like
what they've done and they've retired
and now they're farmers and they're kind
of saying well we're lucky because we
didn't get killed we didn't get arrested
or hanged or anything like that we were
kind of allowed to live out our golden
years just like on a farm and in peace
which um that kind of didn't deserve
that they didn't deserve they deserved
right actually but and that's another
thing that's another thing that the
movie kind of like highlights that your
fate like a lot of people don't get what
they deserve like the two of them were
like the worst of the worst yeah but
they you know they retired and they were
living and actually William Money had a
wife she had passed away like three
years previously he had kids two little
kids and um Ned had a wife as well like
a common law wife yeah uh Sally right
Sally two trees yeah she was an Indian
woman yeah yeah he calls her an engine
well she's an engine well she don't take
two you know they're not real kindly but
they're not real friendly not real
friendly because she always hated me she
knew she knew I was bad yeah he's like
well yeah but that's what's so sad is
that the the whole situation like the
William money's character in particular
and I had forgotten because Clint
Eastwood you know directed and
everything and he was like so much part
of the marketing you forget that like
Clint Eastwood doesn't actually show up
in the movie until like a little bit
later on because kind of you still have
all of the stuff with Gene Hackman and
the prostitutes and everything and then
only later on like once the prostitutes
you know put out the message about the
money and then then there's the whole
thing with English Bob and everything
but then Clint Eastwood he's like oh I
heard about this thousand dollars and I
could really use it because my farm is
failing and then he goes actually he
only hears about it because that kid the
Scofield kid comes and tells him about
it because the Scofield kid is another
kind of romanticizing like he's heard of
William money because he's like a legend
he's like the worst [ __ ] criminal
like worst Outlaw you know what I mean
yeah he's worse than John Wesley Arden
yeah who's worse than that John Wesley
wasn't that bad he just had a [ __ ]
bad reputation there was a lot worse
ones
um
yeah they have this they have this Trio
of these Outlaws two of them are retired
and who summons them into back into the
into the game is this young kid called
the Schofield kid and there's why they
call you the Schofield kid you're from
Schofield there's no because I carry
this Schofield revolver and I'm thinking
me and Jenny are laughing yeah like
everybody else I said you might as well
call him gun boy yeah your name is gut
boy everybody's got those and he's
making all these [ __ ] proud both so
he killed five men or six men and you
know including Mexicans and which that's
another thing is that that
that in in a good western movie you got
to include the influence of the Mexicans
there were a lot of Mexicans inside the
American territory and they were players
in it okay uh it's I don't even think
they showed any Mexicans in this did
they I do not think there were any
Mexicans yeah all that Southwest stuff
here was Mexicans Mexican Cowboys are in
there Mexican gunfighters there's more
of that and like good bad the ugly and
Fistful of Dollars there's you know the
Sergio Leone included a lot of EX gifts
all right which they were they were you
gotta they were good characters
they depend on the region anyway
um he's uh real boastful uh and uh he's
kind of looking he kind of talks big and
looks down her noses at these older guys
sometimes he he looks up to him but then
looks down at him depending on yeah the
arrogance of you yeah yeah he's he's uh
he's insecure too yeah because he's
lying he didn't kill anybody no and uh
he's also got a really bad eyesight he's
[ __ ] he can't see Pat far he can't
see like past 50 yards I can't really
see yeah it turns out one of the things
he wants to do with his money is get
some spectacles yeah uh he wants some
spectacles and and find find clothes
[Laughter]
which that kind of comes into play later
anyway
um
when when it turns out at the end after
he scores his first kill the Scofield
kid he realizes that wasn't as cool as
he thought it was he started [ __ ]
busting up about it you know crying a
bit you know because he shot the dude
while he was on the [ __ ] commode what
would even commode his Outhouse yeah he
shot him in this while he was taking a
[ __ ] right and so it wasn't as glorious
as he thought it was you know but here's
the thing that's realistic yeah you know
me being ex-infantry no man you're dude
you're raiding enemy you're trained to
raid enemy camps while they're asleep
Sometimes using stealth you know what I
mean machine gunning people why they're
still in their sleeping bags as quickly
as possible it's not you know it's it's
it's about as Brave as dropping a bomb
on somebody you know what I mean well
that's what I'm saying it's just
business it's not in it's not it's not
some glorified wow heroic thing like out
of a damn
old-fashioned war movie or something
nice murder nah real combats that's kind
of like and that's like I said that's
kind of like a big like uh you know
central theme of this movie is that you
know when he because William Money tells
him it's like oh hey he just they saw
him go in the Outhouse because they were
watching the house and he's like there's
a good did you go get it go get him yeah
you know so Scofield kid goes and gets
him and like he hesitates too like even
though the guy obviously can't get away
because he's in there like sitting on
the can and uh you know and he's in this
little Outhouse so he finally shoots him
like that but then like afterward he's
just crying and he's just like yeah I
never shot anybody and like probably
Clint Eastwood's like yeah I could tell
yeah pretty much uh from the beginning
but he's like I never want to kill
another person ever again like you don't
feel good that first one's [ __ ] hard
you know what I mean yeah I mean he said
you know not only didn't it feel good
but it wasn't anything like he imagined
that it was gonna be he thought it was
gonna be this big glorious like badass
kind of thing and it wasn't he just like
shot the Dude down download [ __ ] down
low and dirty right and that's the
normal military situation too A lot of
people what are you talking about a
proud U.S army it's not the way it
really is okay uh
military Doctrine dictates that you want
three to one numerical Supremacy over
the enemy before you attack so first of
all you must outnumber the enemy before
you really want to attack and you always
want to time the attack so you were at
your most alert and strongest and they
are at their least alert and weakest
so pre-dawn that's usually where you
want to do it or in really bad weather
because you want the advantage every
Advantage because when you think about
it you as a commander you're you're
your responsibility is to bring as many
of your guys home as possible
a fair fight is not what you're looking
for if you want to bring your guys home
you basically want as close to murder as
possible that's what an ambush is that's
what a raid is you know
so even the military is like this
so that's why William money's like yeah
yeah welcome to the club this is what
it's really like yeah he's like so it's
not a he's like yeah you now you see why
I'm so [ __ ] up yeah yeah because
William mine's got PTSD seeing visions
of his dead wife heads busted open with
maggots in her and he's dead people are
visiting him and is losing his mind with
fever sometimes you know
it's um because it's it's down low yeah
he's and he's like having a hard time
too because he kind of felt like his
wife and his kids like redeemed him to a
degree but then like after his wife died
he seems like he's kind of lost the plot
a little bit and like I said the farm is
kind of going downhill and he's not
really sure how he's going to be able to
support his kids going forward so which
is what you know gets him kind of sucked
into this whole thing to start with see
William Monty had killed so many people
that killing a new person kind of
alleviates the pain of the last one
which is a phenomenon that you'll hear
people talk about sometimes you're
involved in a lot of times it's like in
a tribal type Warfare the first person
you kill it's traumatic so you feel kind
of numb from it and a lot of those
armies will try to make sure that guy
kills another person as quickly as
possible and it kind of replaces
the psychological effects of the first
one it's kind of like if you ever hit
your hand you'll feel pain and it'll get
kind of numb if you hit it again it
feels good they start to get addicted to
being in that right which is probably
something like what a serial killer does
yeah similar but it's just more about
high intensity gun fighting and shooting
people in fights and stuff
um but uh General butt naked talked a
little bit like that says that once you
you know he was African warlord yeah we
did a show about him yeah
um it says once once your soldiers start
killing people you want to keep the ball
rolling and keep them killing as much as
possible or they'll start to question
what they're doing
and start to have psychological problems
strange huh but that's just the way it's
not really that strange I mean it kind
of makes sense when you think because
each successive killing reinforces
the ones before as if you're justifying
what you're doing
you're saying this is part of yeah the
well the farther you get into it like
the more it's kind of like same time
yeah normal more part of you sure so
that's where William money is in this
but he's been in it too long he's now
old and breaking down you can't lie to
himself anymore because he's telling Ned
that one dude I shot remember that
Coachman I shot in the mouth and it says
and his teeth went flying out their back
because yeah I remember that he goes he
didn't do anything he deserve to be shot
and he goes yeah he was a crazy son of a
[ __ ] back then
Ned's trying to chill him out and keep
him yeah cool because he can tell that
he's like losing it yeah and he's he
feels bad I mean Ned feels bad too but
yeah I mean and Ned was not quite as bad
as William money was but it's you're led
to believe that he's almost as bad
because they hung out in the same time
and they're admitting that it didn't
really have anything to do with the
organized crime or anything like that or
any higher goal a lot of it just had to
do with being real drunk and getting
pissed off and getting in fights yep and
it really wasn't anything and you just
shooting an innocent bystander yeah just
random ass people for just for looking
at you funny or something you know yeah
yeah you're it's implied that that's
what a lot of his kills were so there
wasn't like I said there was no glory in
them no anything like that there wasn't
even a reason behind me no just pure
meanness yeah yeah
you know what's um interesting about
this too if you think about it uh when I
was like reading some stuff uh behind
the scenes about this movie is that it's
actually Loosely kind of based on The
Iliad okay like the the plot of it is
kind of like very very similar also I
didn't realize but the concept of this
movie goes all the way back to the
mid-1970s
um they were actually thinking about
doing I think back then it was called
the cut horror killings and um they were
giving it to Clint Eastwood even back
then or even like in the 80s and he
didn't really wanted he want he wanted
to do some other stuff first like before
he got around to it and once he got
around to making it because it came out
in 1992. he kind of felt like well this
was his definitive statement on the
western so he didn't really want to make
any westerns anymore after that because
this was kind of like his
this is it this is like the the big like
you know well I would say story and
writing wise this is the perfect Western
it yeah it really does seem to be it
only has one weakness fight and shooting
choreography isn't all that impressive
by today's standards but it doesn't
matter because the story is good enough
the characters are good enough to keep
this movie relevant this this movie is
still a great movie today
had you made this movie today you'd have
had more intense gunfights and better
camera angles and stuff but that's just
not the spirit of this movie
this movie is mostly a series of lessons
yeah and I think that and I think the
thing and I think that would have been a
mistake like to make the the gun fights
and the you know violence seem more
badass or more over the top or more
intense because the whole point of the
movie is that nothing's ever like what
it's romanticized as yeah but that final
[ __ ] confrontation where William goes
into the saloon and [ __ ] attacks the
Posse that was pretty [ __ ] intense
yeah just goes in there just
cold-blooded with a shotgun and just
shoots it on our man and then just works
over a whole crowd of people and
survives it by luck yeah luck and good
shooting you know and he's like aware of
that and aware of it yeah yeah that's
the thing about William is William knew
like when the biographer now starts
talking to him
the biographer was impressed that
everything that he had been told by
these other law men and gunfighters
wasn't true
that this guy's doing this all on luck
yeah luck and Hate
pretty much yeah
and the only reason he survived like I
said was just like
it I mean a Kamikaze mentality he don't
he really cared and the thing about it
was that like you said he didn't really
deserve like his fate he didn't deserve
to still be alive and he said that he
walks up to Little Bill but and points a
gun at him and he goes out and Little
Bill goes I don't deserve this I was
building a house and [ __ ] Williams
says deserve has gotten nothing to do
with it yeah it just shoots him yeah
because you just it's it right your fate
is random right good or bad I mean
that's the thing it's like so much so
much stuff is out of your control yeah
and I think that this was really good
the movie was like really good at
showing that without like pounding you
over the head with it yeah you know what
I mean because like I said you know
Clint Eastwood he killed however many
people he killed I don't think they ever
said how many people he killed uh all
together in that final one oh I mean in
his whole career in his whole career
yeah yeah oh man they're they're like a
lot yeah leading you to believe at least
50. yeah that it was like yeah that they
lost track you know some of them were
just innocent people right that gave him
a funny look you know when he was in a
bad mood he just shot him yeah probably
but then you know witnessed a shootout
or something and he just boom don't look
at me like that well like I said you
know yeah did Little Bill deserve to get
shot in the face while he was laying
down no probably not
um you know he wasn't a good guy but he
didn't really deserve that but you know
did William Money deserve to still be
alive and have like nice two kids and a
farm and all that other kind of stuff
and have a peaceful life no he didn't
deserve that either because he was a
terrible human being now what what
William money was doing just shooting
bystanders and [ __ ] there's a there's
military there's a call in the military
for that also
when you're uh if you're in an infantry
unit back in the day back when infantry
really went to real Wars all right not
really these police actions like they do
today but World War II style [ __ ] when
you attack an enemy objective in other
words it's a place where the enemy is
you're maximizing violence on the enemy
that's that's you're instructed to do
that which means you kill everyone
all right now you're trying to maximize
psychological damage and cause as much
Panic as possible so they will turn and
run because when they're running it's a
lot easier to shoot them in the back
there's a reason for all that [ __ ]
they're trying you're trying to Route
them you know
well that's kind of what William money's
describing they're just trying to route
an entire downtown area get the [ __ ] out
of here I'll kill anybody you know
that's basically what the message that
which
statistically you'd live longer probably
as as an outlaw doing that in that in
the 1800s that would probably promote
survival people would be afraid to talk
about you or they'd be too Panic to be
able to describe you accurately or they
might not be able to identify you in a
lineup there might have been a lot of
different ways and it's so you're a lot
safer if you're outnumbered against a
bunch of people if everybody's running
from you and if they're just standing
there you don't know if one of them's
got a gun in their pocket right so yeah
there would be a reason why you would do
that if you thought about it
just being mean as hell just [ __ ] try
to put Terror in them and get everybody
to run
yeah pretty much yeah you know promote
survival you know another thing that
actually surprised me when I was like
doing research about this movie was that
um where do you think that this movie
was shot
looking at it I'd say California but
probably not probably Italy
Alberta Alberta Alberta Canada okay
isn't that crazy like almost all of it
was shot in Alberta it looked like
California did it that's what I thought
yeah yeah I thought it was yeah like
Somewhere Out West somewhere like
California or like some of New Mexico or
something it looked like the base of
Sierra Nevada mountain chain around that
area that's exactly what it looked like
but nope it was apparently Alberta
Canada and I was like that blew my mind
I was like I didn't know any part of
Alberta looked like that shows what I
know I've never been to Canada so you
know what I mean all right so you have
anything else you would like to add
about the classic flick man it must be
classic classic even if you don't like
westerns yeah um because I'm not a huge
I like some westerns but I'm not a huge
Western fan but this is a great great
movie just it's not just yeah it's it's
a good movie it has kind of Gothic
elements to it it has
um uh organized crime or gangster type
elements in it it just happens to be set
in the old west and it's got a lot of
morality lessons in it
revolving around violence what that's
like you know yeah and what
civilizations like
and like I said it has kind of like a a
theme about
people's Fates uh how random they are
and also like I said mythologizing like
that nothing's really like the way that
you also the here that it is the
Dynamics the tension between factions
you know what I mean the Cowboys versus
the hookers versus the law enforcement
versus Outlaws
you know versus like a psychopathic
serial killer basically or multiple mass
murderer which is what [ __ ] which is
what money was he was a [ __ ] mass
murderer
show you that yeah but yeah this is a
great flick and uh you should see it
like I said even if you're not really
into westerns it's just like a good
movie Just period regardless of genre so
that will do it for this movie
retrospective we'll see you guys again
on the next one
bye